in other court news recently the Supreme
Court in the state of Pennsylvania
told Republicans in the state that their
districts they had drawn were so
gerrymandered that they had to go back
and redraw them because there was no way
the Republicans could ever lose in that
state basically the Republicans said
okay we're gonna do that but just please
do us a favor state Supreme Court could
we just do it after this year's midterm
elections we kind of have a lot going on
Supreme Court understandably said no you
can't wait
you have until February 15th to get this
done or else we're gonna do it for you
and it has to be done before the
midterms and so the Republicans didn't
get it the Supreme Court is now in
charge of redrawing these lines and this
week Donald Trump decided that the rule
of law in the United States doesn't
matter Donald Trump told Republicans via
Twitter that they need to ignore the
Supreme Court of the state of
Pennsylvania's ruling that these
districts have to be redrawn before the
midterms he does not believe that
Republicans in the state of Pennsylvania
should adhere to these new districts
that are being drawn why because he
thinks that the redrawing is gonna
benefit the Democrats too darn much well
let me tell you something the way the
districts were drawn in the state of
Pennsylvania and the reports on it say
that they were essentially like
tentacles stretching out into some areas
of the state and bending and curving and
winding to grab every little last
Republican in those areas and in the
last election more votes were cast for
Democrats in Pennsylvania and yet
somehow miraculously Republicans won the
majority of the seats because of the
gerrymandered districts which means even
though the majority of people in the
state of Pennsylvania wanted to be
represented by Democrats they got left
with Republicans because that's how
badly it was gerrymander
the Supreme Court understood that they
recognized it and they said look you
can't do this so here is our decision
which means it's the law and Donald
Trump is out there actively telling
Republican politicians in the state of
Pennsylvania to ignore the rule of law
now I myself I'm no legal scholar I know
a little bit about it but to me when you
have someone in a position of power over
another person and you tell them to
ignore the law which means you tell them
to break the law that's illegal
what Donald Trump is telling these
Republicans to do in the state of
Pennsylvania could actually be
considered a crime in the United States
he is instructing people to break the
law because that Supreme Court decision
is the law so by telling these
Republicans to not adhere to these
redrawn districts to not follow what the
court says to ignore the rule of law
Donald Trump once again could find
himself on the wrong side of American
law but don't worry nothing's gonna
happen to him nobody's gonna pay
attention to this this is an issue like
so many other things unfortunately
that's gonna die away Donald Trump could
virtually encima Lee at some points just
get away with anything but could you
imagine the responses if Barack Obama
ever told anyone ever to ignore the law
could you imagine what would have
happened at that point I mean he'll at
this point could you imagine if Barack
Obama had done half the things that
Donald Trump has done or even just said
some of the things Donald Trump has done
my god we would have had an armed
revolution in this country led by the
folks at Fox and Friends
but instead when the when Trump says it
when it's their guy their president the
guy they helped put in office it's fine
he's right you know
we shouldn't listen to this supreme
court that knows more about the law than
we ever could no no listen to listen to
the guy who's bankrupted you know a
dozen businesses he knows what he's
talking about right
No Donald Trump is absolutely one of the
most dim-witted president certainly the
most dim-witted president of my lifetime
which is saying a lot for George W Bush
but he's only you know a tick above him
but the bottom line is that you can't
encourage people to break the law
especially when you're the president of
the United States because that could be
seen as a direct order to those people
to go and break the law and I hope that
there is a lawyer listening to this that
says you know what maybe that's the
crime we can pop him on maybe we don't
have to wait for the end of the Muller
investigation maybe we could use this
particular Proclamation by the President
to finally bring an end to this
disastrous presidency because you know
what you may not be happy with rulings
from the court systems but guess what
once they come down that's the law
that's the law of the land their job is
to interpret and so that's what the
Supreme Court in the state of
Pennsylvania did now Donald Trump is not
the only one out there trying to
undermine these judges we do have
Republicans in the state of Pennsylvania
in the Statehouse led by Republican
representative Chris douche who wants to
impeach the justices on that
Pennsylvania Supreme Court because they
ruled that their gerrymandered districts
were illegal so think about that we have
the President of the United States
saying ignore the ruling and then we
have Republicans in Pennsylvania saying
these judges did something we don't like
so let's remove them from office that is
how desperate Republicans are to keep
these gerrymandered districts so that
they do not get the expected blue tidal
wave that could be headed towards them
in this coming November they're willing
to break the law or at least encourage
law breaking they're willing to impeach
law-abiding justices because they
disagree with them just to preserve
their own jobs that they obviously know
are the result of gerrymandering if
those districts had not been drawn that
way if the state had been divided up
evenly and fairly many of these people
would not have jobs today especially
people like representative Chris douche
they're trying to impeach all these
judges here listen we have to take a
quick break I am fair and cousin sitting
in for David Pakman David will be back
tomorrow
but you can follow me on Twitter at fair
and balanced you can find me on youtube
youtube.com slash the Ring of Fire you
can check out Ring of Fire online at TR
o fire calm we've got daily videos going
up myself Mike Papantonio David Pakman
Sam cedar Tom Hartman Abby Martin so go
check it out TR o fire calm I'm fairing
cousins and for David Pakman and we'll
be right back